[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Now this week during
our annual Developer Day
at the Game
Developers Conference,
we introduced new tools to
improve the overall discovery
on Google Play,
especially supporting
developers who build
high-quality and engaging
games.
This includes more curation
of high-quality games
through editorial
pages and promoting
high-quality experiences
based on engagement,
not just installs.
More details, as well as a
peek at some upcoming games,
are on the post linked
in the description below.
The official Firebase SDKs for
Unity and C++ are now generally
available to help you
supercharge your games.
This means that they're both
primary supported platforms
that Firebase is committed
to supporting in the future.
Check out the post
for everything
you can take advantage of,
a Getting Started guide,
and a set of new samples.
We recently announced
the launch of a new way
to publish apps on Google
Play with some new features.
The changes will
give you the ability
to manage your app releases
with more confidence
via a new Manage Releases
page in Google Play Developer
Console.
Screenshots and a
video are on the post.
tf.Transform is a new
library for TensorFlow
that allows users to define
pre-processing pipelines
and run these using
large-scale data
processing frameworks,
while also exporting
the pipeline in a way that can
be run as part of a TensorFlow
graph.
You'll want the flowchart for
this one, and it's on the post.
Google Cloud Platform is
the first cloud provider
to offer the next
generation Intel Xeon
processor, code-named Skylake.
Skylake includes Intel
Advanced Vector Extensions,
which make it ideal for
scientific modeling,
genomic research, 3D-rendering,
data analytics, and engineering
simulations.
All the links are in
the description below.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TYPING]
Thank you for watching this
week's episode of The Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior work,
check out the links just
to my left, your right.
There.
[MUSIC PLAYING]